[Applaudissements]
y'a pas mon benhaim qui fait du 36
chalon a déjà au pied alors je vais vous
dire je vais prendre déjà tout de suite
et jean michel vous faites du convient
de 443 excusez moi parce qu'on va pas
rester deux heures donc si vous déposez
les chaussures que le grill vraiment
choisir mais social ça va mais c'est le
gars qui scanne et moi je vais vous dire
je suis laissé aller c'est gérard louvin
venez là gérard louvin qui doit faire
qui doit faire du 44 voix 44 jean luc
joly jean-luc et il y prenait celle que
vous voulez attention les fenêtres cina
qui arrive aux problèmes bien j'en crois
les 43 allez-y c'est choisi s'il vous
plaît faites samedi
merci je vais vous dire il ya un
aller-retour à faire s'il vous plaît
regarde regarde et thierry moreau est
magnifique dessus je me demande si ça
lui va pas mieux
attention un aller-retour à faire [ __ ]
et cela alors moi je suis arbitre
forcément le titre ne peut pas non plus
faire la ps vita il ne peut pas tout
faire et attend jean michel maire est
prêt en tout cas derrière moi et ça lui
va comme un gant
mais ces bannis et joseph joe lui est
magnifique attention les gars vous allez
pas mettez-vous là vous faites un aller
retour
donc attention christina christine
allait faire avec eux aussi attention un
peu on a perdu
vous n'irez pas des météorites qui
avaient vécu avec la peinture
métaphysique
atos émettra graves aux marques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
mais